good evening and welcome to
stratford-on-avon District Council
planning committee my name is councilor
Lewis Adam I'm your chairman for this
evening
I'm just going to run through some
housekeeping then we'll get on to the
agenda um there's no fire drill planned
so if it does go off please
um evacuate the building and the muster
station is in the car park by the pub
across the road this is a
meeting in public not a public meeting
and so only those who are registered to
speak will be allowed to do so
um I'll call you forward at the right
time in the agenda and give you further
instructions at that point the meeting
is being recorded and broadcast online
and I'd like to remind everyone present
to please keep your phones on silent so
that they don't disrupt the flow of the
meeting
right I'll now introduce the top table
we've got Olivia Quinn from democratic
Services
um we have Amy Shipley who is our legal
advisor this evening our planning
manager is Dale Barker and our planning
officers are in no particular order
Sarah Leach Victoria Kempton and Louise
Coleman I believe there you have a
statement you preferred I do thank you
chairman my role tonight is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist assist
members decision taking thank you chair
thank you very much right on to item
number one apologies for absence
and counselor councilor passing him who
councilor hatch is substituting for
I love you thank you very much item two
disclosures of interest do we have any
disclosures of interest for the agenda
know nothing very good okay in which
case item number three minutes
um the reports pack includes minutes
from the meeting held on the 25th of May
2023 particularly World opportunity to
see them
Castle Harvey
um I don't have any objection to the
minutes I would be interested to know
why it is on the 16th of August we're
considering minutes of the 25th of May
is there an explanation for that
I I'm happy to have a quick uh answer
from democratic Services otherwise we'll
move on
um it was simply because it was missed
and we added them onto the next agenda
thank you Olivia
um are we all happy there are a good
representation meeting agreed Johnny
good okay we've also got minutes from
the 19th of July
2023. I'm happy they're uh honest
representation of the meeting everyone
else happy
agreed jolly good okay
um moving on to item number four uh
which is our first application
application 22
02138 ful land off North Station Road
fenney Compton uh presenting officer is
Louise calderman when you're ready take
it away
thank you chair this is an outline
application for the erection of 12
custom and self-built dwellings with all
matters reserved except for the access
the application site is located on the
Eastern edge of feney Compton which is
identified by the black dot on the map
the site which is demarked by the red
line is approximately 0.77 hectares and
comprises of a single Paddock currently
overgrown with scrub on the Southern and
Eastern boundaries of the site there are
established hedgerows there's a
children's play area and playing fields
to the Northwest and dwellings on
Thompson's field during the western
boundary a dilapidated building lies in
the Southeastern corner of the site
which is also proposed to be demolished
as part of the development
the site joins the built-up area
boundary of the village and forms a
small part of the larger feni Compton
Meadows potential local Wildlife site
access to the site is proposed through
the adjoining Thompson's field estate
and the established hedgerows and tree
planting around the periphery of the
site is proposed to be retained and
secured by ensuring these areas lie
outside of the plot cartilages an
attenuation Basin is proposed within a
Northeastern corner of the site and a
pedestrian link provided the
Northwestern corner to allow access to
their joining playoff fields
the application has been accompanied
with a design code which sets out the
development principles consideration
parameters taken into account the local
context and character of the area the
design code includes the use of sustain
so sorry suitable materials separation
distances building lines active frontal
frontages and Boundary treatments which
would need to be adhered to in any
subsequent Reserve matter application
building Heights would also be limited
to 8.5 meters in order to be in keeping
with the adjoining residential
development
the site is proposed to be accessed off
Thompson's Fields as shown in the
photograph which comprises of a mix of
two-story properties and a couple of
bungalows
the access into the site is via an
existing tuning header joining 10 and 11
Thompson's field this photo shoot shows
the existing approach into the site
This Is A View From Within the site
looking in a southwesterly direction
showing the relationship of the
properties in Thompson's field and
existing fuel boundaries
this is a view looking to the South
adjoining the um
Highway and the existing tree and
Hedgerow cover is proposed to be
retained
this is a view looking towards the
Southeastern corner of the site and they
dilapidated it out outbuilding which is
proposed to be removed
and then finally looking uh towards the
northern boundary which abuts the
playing fields
um chairman there are no updates to
report and the recommendation is to
Grant subjects in the completion of a
section 106 agreement and the condition
notes as detailed in the report thank
you
thank you very much uh just for clarity
I believe I misspoke when introducing
this item the application reference is
02138 out okay we'll move on to our
first Speaker who is councilor John
Dutton the chairman of Penny Compton
Parish Council
uh it either will be fine
um okay uh councilor Dutton you have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning um before the end if you press
the button on the right and that will
take the microphone arrive and uh when
you're ready please take it away
firstly uh if any Compton's neighborhood
development plan was started in January
2017 and was made in April 2023. this
NDP included a housing needs survey with
no requirement for self or custom built
housing was identified
the NDP was extensively reviewed by many
parties including the district council
and at no point did anyone identify a
requirement for our plan to make
reference to Legal obligations in other
parties specifically relating to self or
custom build it's therefore extremely
frustrating having been sold the promise
that this plan would carry significant
weight in a testing and planning
applications that the absence of perhaps
single sentence means that the plan is
afforded a lesser weight
we don't believe this is fair or
appropriate and ask the committee to
give our neighborhood development plan
greater weight than they are suggested
in the report
secondly we do not agree with the
planning Department's assessment of the
sustainability of this development we
are in a rural setting with limited
access to public transport we have
already committed to the development of
100 new affordable properties in the
Compton dock site which increases the
population of both the parish by about a
third with no improvements to
infrastructure or facilities it's
difficult to argue that a development of
12 properties tips the balance between
what is sustainable and what is not but
there appears to be no definition of
what is or isn't sustainable and
therefore the planner's assessment that
the development is not that the
development is sustainable but there is
no specific evidence that it's
unsustainable the remainder of Station
Road could accommodate another 200
houses at the same density as the
Compton locks development
and there appears to be no mechanism to
stop this if these are applied for in
smaller Parcels masquerading as
self-build we request the committee
recognize the specific characteristics
of our parish and the applications
already granted within it in assessing
the sustainability of this proposal
finally we believe the assessment of the
supply shortfall presented in the report
applies an overly conservative view only
counting properties which part two cell
exemptions have been requested the
number of people on the register in
October 2019 was 131 and by October 2022
239 plots with part one cell extension
have been provided this is a significant
oversupply of almost double relative to
the obligation however only 55 of these
plots are requested part two cell
exemptions therefore the other
184 permissions are disregarded despite
the fact that this period includes a
covered pandemic was called massive
disruption to all parts of society and
the economy including construction we
disagree with the assertion that the
shortfall between demand and Supply
exists in all probability as states in
the report
therefore in summary we asked the
committee to refuse this application
because it is in contravention of our
neighborhood development plan it is not
demonstrably sustainable and the
available data does not demonstrate the
supply is not being met thank you
thank you very much just within your
time members do we have any questions
about Parish counselor
no in which case I think you're free to
go thank you very much
right so we now move on to our next
speaker who is Mr Jeff Armstrong
good evening uh same procedure so you've
got three minutes uh spoken on the right
to um
that's it I'll give you a 30 second
warning and feel free to start when
you're ready thank you chair I'm I'm
pleased to be able to address the
committee today to speak about our
client ligan homes proposal for the 12
self-build dwellings on the site in
question
the application was submitted following
detailed pre-application discussion with
officers in 2021 at which point there
were 163 entries on the self-built
register this has now increased to 283
entries as of October of last year
and your officer has confirmed that the
demand for such plot is growing at a
faster rate
than Supply which then Supply which has
resulted in a considerable shorefall
your officer's report presents a
comprehensive assessment of the proposed
development and as such I do not intend
to predict onto detail today it is
sufficient to say that there are no
technical objections from any statutory
Consulting
in response to the comments from
councilor Rock which is set out in the
committee report
our client is pleased that he considers
that the site is suitable in some
respects but we note that he questions
whether there's be there is a proven
need from persons residing in the
district wishing to build in this
locality
in response to this point your officer's
report represents a detailed breakdown
of the number of people on the
self-built register and the number of
permissions granted this clearly
demonstrates that there is currently a
shortfall in supply of at least 67 plots
counting just those with for people with
a local connection
Council Rock also permitted that he
considered the original submitted design
code to be too prescriptive
as confirmed in your officers report the
design code has been revised during the
course of the application to ensure that
it was not overly prescriptive whilst
including sufficient guidance to ensure
an appropriate development
Council Rock did not make any further
comments on the application following
the amendments to the design code
in response to the comments both written
and verbal from the parish council that
the site is in an unsustainable location
and that is not as and that is not a
small Escape small scale scheme sorry we
would first highlight that the site was
previously identified as a reserve
housing site for 15 dwellings in the
site allocations preferred options it
has therefore been identified as a
suitable location for housing of the
scale proposed your officer agrees with
this assessment stating that it is
considered that the proposal would be
small scale given the size and nature of
fenney Compton and would be in keeping
with the established Carriage of the
area
the site is located outside but a joint
in the settler boundary and your office
concludes that the principal are
development is acceptable given the high
need for self-built plots in the area
subject to the legal requirements set
out in the 106 to deliver this
requirement
I hope this will be hope that you'll be
able to support our development and I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you very much just within your
time
um already got questions coming from
councilor Pemberton
thank you very much
um
to frame my question can we assume I'm
on the register
I come to Langham homes
I wanna I wanna self-build custom
property
walk me through
um while I'm actually doing myself to
what extent is this me in control of
this project that it is custom
self-built rather than I'm just buying a
house from Langan just tell me tell me
what my options are what can I choose I
know there's a design code but you know
what can choice and control do I have
tell me demonstrate to me it's self
build please
well the the mechanism
that the site will be marketed for a
period of time 12 months
during that time people will then
contact Lagan as part of the market
campaign
if there is interest and if a deal is
concluded between the parties then a
reserve matter application will be
submitted to yourselves your planning
offices within processor application and
that Reserve matter would be specific to
the pot the plot in question
by which time whilst these discussions
are ongoing lagging will basically put
in the infrastructure work to enable the
services to be provided to the place uh
can I I think I understand all of that
bit okay I want to know on a detailed
basis
if I want to build
an art deco design if I want to build
some other design I want complete
control over the internal layout I want
to be able to choose because I would say
that this is an outline application so
we would have to keep the questions
relevant what's in front of the
principal chair of whether this is
custom and self-built so I think it is
not an unreasonable question at outline
and I'm I'm going to seek legal officer
of opinion on that I don't think it's an
unreasonable question to ask it is
the the application is being presented
and is being purported to meet and
overcome a number of policy barriers on
the basis that is custom and self-build
I believe that it is right and proper
for these for us as decision makers to
satisfy ourselves at these custom and
self-build and for me that goes to the
heart of the detail not what I want to
know what the choice is you know if this
is a palette you know or have I got real
Choice thank you chair Mr Pemberton I
think you might be looking for the words
primary input in your question
Mr Barker
he that should be obeyed
so do you want me to respond if you're
happy with my line chair
respond just
um
there is a design code which was
explained by your officers and it set
out in massive detail in the uh
committee report we originally submitted
a quite detailed design code which set
out the parameters of the dwelling the
height of the dwelling uh whether it's a
two-story what materials could be used
what the the garden would consist of and
your officers asked us to pay that back
uh it did it varies differently for some
authorities want more control others
want less control in this instance the
less control is what we responded to
which does give more flexibility to your
point earlier for a self-builder to come
along and build within a very broad
design called the type of house they
want so clearly it's not a free-for-all
there are some limited controls to
ensure that there is a consistency of
plot size overall height and massing but
then within that the choice of materials
that style of window the type of
roofscape all those matters are left for
a reserve matter to come in for you and
your officers to consider as to whether
it's acceptable or not
so it is it is certainly a route I would
prefer to go down it gives far more
flexibility and option for the
self-builder or custom builder to come
along uh and by the site and develop the
house
thank you I think that's uh very concise
um councilor Perry next
thank you chair good evening
um I would actually like to know the
rationale behind the design in terms of
putting the access
from Thompson Fields rather than the
main road the rationale behind that
question is that in our experience in
the district
um self-build custom build housing is
taking quite often three or four years
for a site to complete my concern is for
the residents that actually live in
Thompson Fields they're going to have a
construction site and vehicles moving
past their properties for up to five
years because of the time scale so I'd
like to know why
The Proposal wasn't put for a um a
direct access off the feney Compton Road
which is not a hugely busy road and one
would have expected to have seen the
this particular self-build custom site
having its own in
access rather than going through an
existing existing residential site
it was a topic which we raised at the
beginning of the process it was a
solution which we had considered
but it was um it wasn't successful in
terms of negotiation with higher
authority had a strong preference that
we use the existing access we go through
the existing site next door
and when we looked at the sight lines
required I know it's not a busy road but
the sight lines required to get that
access to work it would involve the
removal of most of the Hedge through
there and obviously from an ecology
point of view and from a BNG point of
view that was something which we didn't
want to go down and I think it was
certainly the advice we were getting
from your officers that they didn't want
to see that hedge removed in fact they
wanted to say that age retained such to
the point that we've actually got a
buffer script next to that hedge to make
sure it's got longevity in terms of its
maintenance going forward so there were
two reasons one was a loss of Hedgerow
the second was the highway Authority
being quite insistent on using the
existing access
thank you councilor hatch Nick
um I've got two questions if that's okay
first one is are you able to give us a
rough budget of what these plots will
sell for and the second one is
um what happens after the 12 months if
they're not sold
sorry I just interject um the the first
question in terms of the price isn't
relevant to the planning process but I
believe the second one was fine
yeah
perfect answer but the reality is we
don't know what the price is going to be
anyway so I couldn't save you uh to
answer the second point after the 12
months
um there would be then a review in
discussion a review with your officers
just to what the future would hold on on
that particular site so we would have
had to have done more marketing both for
cut for self-built after custom build
during that 12 month period okay and we
would share that response with your
officers during the process we have to
agree through the 106 a mechanism by
which we would let that information flow
between ourselves and new offices uh and
after the 12 months we will then have to
have a discussion again with your
officers as to what the next what the
next step would be
we have no plans to not to fail in that
area we're very keen and very positive
that actually we'll get a lot of
interest and we should be able to get an
interest very quickly from some very
early marketing which we'd like to do if
we're successful tonight
thank you any further questions
counselor Keithley
Council of rocks objections
yes in respect of the demand for these
properties and I think you said that um
demand was demonstrated because there
were 283 entries on the register and
demand was growing so there's a
shortfall
but I think you didn't answer the second
point that councilor Rock raised which
is a sort of secondary level of data
that I think we're entitled to ask in
these circumstances and that is whether
or not you've ascertained more local
demand in the southeast of the district
or in the fenney Compton area and the as
I understand it the neighborhood
development plan uh didn't identify the
need for any self and custom built
properties do you have any further
information that you could um share with
us on the demand in this particular
locality rather than district-wide the
district stretches from
Ulster and Studley if you're living in
Studley you're probably not looking for
a self and custom-built property in
fenney Compton
I I think the evidence which we've um
would point you to is the evidence that
set out in the committee report if you
look under the it's it's not numbered
but the supply and demand section for
self-build and custom housing in the
district
um on the second page which starts on
the 31st of October
you've got the 283 on the register
and then you go to the second paragraph
you then say that there is a shortfall
of 76 while counting only those with a
local connection there are 67 plots so
there is a acknowledgment in the
evidence base produced by your officers
that there is
local connections for self-building this
area
um okay thanks for that response I think
I'm right in saying that the um the
connection is a district-wide connection
and what you've identified is a
district-wide
demand it doesn't answer the question as
to whether or not you've identified
local demandings the southeast of the
district and in particular in the feney
Compton area but thank you
if you have any further questions no in
which case thank you very much
right uh we're now moving on to
um
the ward member the ward member is
registered to speak but unfortunately
neither are um available they have
however provided me their speech uh to
read I believe there was an accompanying
slide sent in
um so we'll just see
okay so uh I believe um Louise is just
getting that up uh but the uh
interest of experience I'm going to
start and uh and we'll go through that
okay
this application is not compliant with
our local policies the sole reason to
consider it is the national regulations
for custom and self-build I chaired a
working group into this subject in 2022
first housing numbers in general terms
the district has double The Five-Year
housing land Supply if any Compton has
just over 300 homes now if any Compton
has already provided 129 to date of the
core strategy requirement to provide 84
dwellings the planning of Spectra has
ruled elsewhere that these requirement
figures are approximate maximums in
fenney Compton we are already 53 over
the approximate maximum and this
proposal will bring it to 67 over by any
measure as set out by the planning
inspectorate this is not a roundabout
the maximum but well over it
there is then the custom and self builds
Act to the report points out on page 36
that there is a probable shortfall
across the whole District the officer
has set out very well in the report on
pages 22 and 23 the numerical situation
on the second paragraph of page 23 the
officer puts the shortfall at 67
for those with a district connection
Stratford on Avon district is 400 square
miles assuming that this probable
requirement of 67 homes is accurate 18
of the district's need are to be
provided here in from one Parish
the Parish of fenny Compton is much less
than one percent of the district by both
area and population and it seems in
Equitable for it to be required to
shoulder such a proportion of the
probable shortfall across the whole
District
can you show the map please if any
Compton is a rural location near the
southeast edge of the district and
residents are heavily dependent on the
use of a private car in fact with a
small shop no Secondary School nearby a
minimal bus service an indirect Road
connection to most of the district as
per map it is one of the worst places to
put a self-built housing estate to meet
the needs of the wider District it is 20
miles from Stratford 16 miles to
shipston 34 miles to Studley and 27
miles to Ulster salvam is the only town
in the district within reasonable
distance and that necessitates car use
with the climate change emergency
brought into focus by recent events we
should not be expanding a remote
settlement with car dependency in excess
of the maximum numbers set in policy nor
the approximate maximum
as detailed by the planning inspectorate
on appeals
the emerging South Warwickshire local
plan has environment and sustainability
as its main and overarching priority
including minimizing travel this
proposal does not fit within those
priorities
as as has been concluded that as10 cs15
cs16 are not consistent with national
self-build policy
this is the case as the core strategy
preceded the introduction of the 2015
and 2016 custom and self-built acts
nevertheless if any Compton neighborhood
development plan past independent
examination in the summer of 2022 and
was made in April 2023
this is more than eight years after the
custom and self-build acts came into
force and the examiner was apparently
satisfied
the fenney Compton NDP States in section
de 2.2 all areas outside the built up
area boundary are classed as Countryside
new dwellings within the Countryside
should be limited to those exceptions
listed within policy as10 of Stratford
District council's core strategy if any
Compton neighborhood development pan is
the most recent policy document and is
intended to take local wishes into
account the penny Compton NDP
specifically prevents this doc
development being permitted
If This Were was a local self-builder
seeking a single plot in their home area
the position might be different however
this is a speculative development
apparently designed to fulfill a much
wider and speculative demand
as the long-itchington inspector's
decision points out there is no
requirement for the provisions of the
self and custom build act to override
local policies where they are in
Conflict I contend that this is the
situation here and that the development
should not be permitted as the local
policy made by the people of feney
Compton in the NDP specifically states
that they do not wish for any
development to take place outside the
buab in addition the development is at
odds with the climate Council climate
change policy and climate emergency
declaration the application does not
comply with NDP policy 2.2 nor as10 cs15
cs16 therefore the application should be
refused councilor Nigel Rock 11th of
August 2023
right
um obviously I'm not the ward member so
I can't take any questions
um but we have that submission in which
case we can now move on to points of
clarification from the officer councilor
Perry
thank you chair
um
just a couple of oh
just
sorry sorry Council Parry I just note
that counselor gist also supports the
statement I've just read out sorry
continue
um
just a couple of questions if I may
um I received this afternoon
um from Mr Barker via the policy team
an analysis of the custom build register
where it highlights in an Excel
spreadsheet
the demand
and the planning permissions for C1 and
those that have gone to C2
I would like to know from the officers
what weight can be given to the fact
there is no demand that has come from
the feni Compton settlement
um none at all on the register and also
what weight we can give to the
neighborhood development plan
thank you
sorry councilor Perry asked that
question again I slipped Straight Out of
My Head
I have in front of me it can be a
truncated version just remember
um according to the Excel spreadsheet of
the latest up-to-date copy of the
self-build custom build register to the
end of July
2023 which highlights the debarmed from
various settlements across the district
and those applications that have been
put forward there is no reference to any
demand from the settlement of feni
Compton I would like to know what weight
we therefore can give to this
application on the basis there is no
demand of anyone registered
um wishing to to move to Penny Penny
Compton and also what weight we can give
to the approved neighborhood development
plan that has been through the policy
team here at SDC that was made in April
and that the
um Parish Council that there was no
reference raised by the policy team that
they should be including a policy with
regard to self-build and custom build
thank you sorry it's a bit uh yes I'm
sorry to put you through that again
councilor Parry I do apologize
um
but my answer will be much shorter than
your question I promise you
um the first part of the question was
addressed the demand in fenney Compton
specifically and the advice that we have
from your policy team is that the
appropriate level to assess demand is
district-wide and we should not be
passing it at a a lower level a more
intimate level than district-wide and
that's the only answer I can give you
tonight that is the appropriate level
district-wide and the second second part
of the question was what weight should
we give to the NDP well of course you
should give full weight to the policies
of the NDP
um but there are no
I apologize you should give moderate
weight to the policies of the NDP
for the reason set out on page 24 of
your report in the final part of the NDP
uh section so you should give moderate
weight to those policies and of course
there are no policies specifically
addressing uh self and custom build so
you should give weight to the excuse me
you should give weight to the fact that
the self and custom build act requires
you to provide self and custom built
dwellings and you should give
considerable weight to that
thank you councilor Harvey
Jim can I
draw the officer's attention to page 21
first paragraph line three and four
where it states that fenney Compton will
have provided much of its required
housing allocation
what is that required housing allocation
foreign
in answer to that question
um Fanny Compton lies within a category
2 settlement and it's uh if you refer to
page 20 off of my report there's 700
homes in total of which
um
if any Compton has built up to 129 Homes
at present and that equates as I say to
18 and a half percent of the total uh
Category 2 lsv
um total there
um
hopefully that's an answer to your
question no it's not an answer to my
question
um the use of the phrase provided much
of its required housing allocation only
holds water if you can tell me what that
required housing allocation is
to refer to the 129 is the number of
houses that have been built
there is an argument that says the
required number is 84. because that is
12 of 700 as required by cs16 because
cs-16 says that there shall be built no
more than around and I would argue on my
understanding of English
that 129 is not around 84 at all it's
foreign excess and therefore I'm
interested to know why you've used this
phrase much of its required housing
allocation and like you know what
required housing allocation in your
terms actually is
chairman I'm happy for Louise to answer
that question uh in a moment or two but
I'm not sure that it's helping us to
take the debate further forward because
we're not meeting our custom and
self-build requirement so it's
irrelevant
what uh housing numbers have been
achieved that aren't custom and
self-built in this settlement or indeed
in the district
it's it's not part of the uh the the
it's not relevant to the decision making
this afternoon with respect I disagree
with that
um it seems to me that
this application
that the the requirements of cs16 have
already been exceeded and therefore this
application is on top of that
requirement the degree to which cs-16 is
being flouted in this case by this
application is relevant um
I'm happy for you to make that point but
I think that's probably one for the
debate and just keep these to concise
points of clarification
um I believe we're still just going to
get the figures that you did ask for
which well I do believe relevant but
um once we have those we'll move on to
the next question
explain why that
uh yeah through you I I believe the
figure is 84 but I haven't got the table
in front of me I think that but that
should be interpreted is it the wording
of the policy for lsv settlements is
if you bear with me for a moment I have
got in with some text here
where is that
in the text it it says no more than a
round
and I would just uh refer you back to
that that the the wording
um is not uh of no more than it is is
not considered to be
um
a maximum figure because the word around
is also included which means it's not a
precise maximum and therefore needs to
be seen in the The Round In terms of
policy cs16
so it's not considered to be a maximum
figure and we have had multiple appeal
decisions in agreement with that
rationale
thank you councilor Keithley
future
um while I was listening with interest
to counselor rocks
um presentation through your self-chair
and looking at the the map that shows
where funny Compton is in relation to
the rest of the district and I would
like to ask a point of clarification on
page 23 of your report and it's the
penultimate paragraph
and it says that the PPG states that the
local planning authorities should use
the demand date from the registers in
their area we've already had some
information about the register from
councilor Parry
it then goes on to say that is supported
as necessary by additional data from the
second resources to understand and
consider future needs for this type of
housing within their area now what I'd
like clarification on is what are we
entitled to consider in respect of
secondary sources of information
for example are we able to consider
more localized demand for self and
custom-built housing which can be
evidenced by the applicant or other
information from the register
rather than simply a district-wide
information what I'm really seeking to
understand is what greater degree of
granularity can we have
over district-wide information when it
comes to secondary sources
uh of data thank you
German we asked this question of your
policy team and the answer we received
is as follows
the register records that a registrant
wants to sell for custom build the areas
where they might want to build and the
type of property they would like to
build a registrant might nominate
multiple areas that they wish to build
we do not record the personal situation
of the registrant Beyond them living in
the district having close family in the
district working in the district or
having a military Covenant the data
collected is not statutory Beyond name
contact details and that they wish to
self-build in the district and their
ties to the district analysis of
preferred locations on the analysis tab
of the spreadsheet which we can show you
if you wish to see it
shows the settlements across the
district and that's the one that the
councilor parry's been interrogating
um where where demand has been
identified from the registrants the
register asked people where they would
like to build however registrants can
nominate multiple places or in fact
State no preference this can lead to a
position and does where the total number
of places where self-build is requested
outnumbers the number of people on the
register self-build by its nature can be
a much longer process with resources and
funding for projects being ad hoc in
nature rather than committed up front
um that I'm afraid is the only answer I
can offer you chairman
to that I've just looked at the relevant
paragraph and it does say secondary
sources can include data from building
plot search websites inquiries for
building plots recorded by local estate
agents and surveys of local residents
demand assessment tools can also be
utilized
any further questions for officers
oh counselor
I've got a couple about demand it would
be great to because obviously in report
we've only got it up to
last October
um whether we've got an up to date I I
yeah it would be great to know
be not lovely to to have that the
spreadsheet that you've had access to
and
um my other question is
I know my question wasn't relevant about
budget but I know that there are
similar plots of land in ettington that
was sold for 250 000 pounds and when it
would be nice to know on the register a
sort of rough budget because surely not
everybody can afford that and therefore
matching
supply and demand is tricky if people
don't have that
budget
that's a
chairman in answer to the second part of
that question we operate in a market
economy that's the only answer we have
for you okay
in terms of information that we had
today
from the policy team
they had provided this is a synopsis of
the additional information which the key
points are that as of end of July it's
showing that there are currently 310
registrations so you can see
from the information on the report from
October of last year it's increasing
year on year
and as of May there were 238 planning
permissions with still one but as you're
aware we record obviously of only of
those 68 had still two exemption so it's
quite clear that it's still a very clear
under supply of self-build
and we anticipate that that number to
continue in that theme
I have one question actually
um which did occur to me I think it was
um the agent for the application
indicated that this site was identified
uh in the site allocation plan at some
point I understood that it wasn't orbit
I don't think it was a self-built
specific one could you um
illuminate us just on on the the history
of it within the sap please
the critical point chair is that it
isn't in the sap
sites are often considered for
development
um for throughout the the local planning
process it isn't in the sap and I would
urge you to give no weight to uh the
suggestion that it may have been
considered for inclusion in this app at
some point
particularly as we would say that you
would give limited weight to the sap
anyway because of its very early stage
thank you very much councilor Keith Lee
again
uh thank you chair
um yes and I just wanted to clarify
something that um Louise case officer
just said um in respect of this table
that we were looking at you referred to
Sil part two and I think you said that
this table
um in referring to Silk part two shows a
under supply of sights
but what my question is is whether or
not we actually mean an under delivery
of sites because the District Council
is not able to determine the completion
of the sites what it can determine
is the granting of the plots
through the application process but it
can't deliver the completion of the
sites because that's down to market
conditions so can we clarify do we mean
under Supply or do we mean under
delivery in respect of sill too
determined delivery would concern me a
little bit because as you rightly say he
can't deliver them uh so I I wouldn't
want to think that the council
responsible for not delivering when
our contribution towards delivering
is granting sufficient planning
permissions to allow the system out
there to deliver so largely speaking
you've reached the right conclusion
we can only continue to Grant planning
permissions until such time as the
number of pitch number of plots with
sales part one and two equals the demand
that's the critical thing
right any further points of
clarification
in which case we can move to debate who
would like to start we already had some
debate going on so
I'll pick somebody
Castle Fleming
and the reason is that
unless there are some special reasons to
refuse it
we've had a situation only one month ago
In This Very Room
where we had exactly the same Parish
Council saying
we've got more development in the
village than we should have
um we've had the developer saying these
things need to be built I've had the
parish council saying it's outside the
built-up area boundary same here same
there
and this so we've had in an actual fact
we've had two previous uh applications
were very similar nature and size to
this one
and despite all the uh all the problems
and all the the arguments against
We've Ended up granting planning
permission for them
and uh and I like I say from from my
perspective I don't see anything new
in this uh in the objections to this
application that would make me refuse
this one any more than it made me do the
others so from that perspective
um from what I've seen already I think I
would be supporting the officer's
recommendation
okay
thank you counselor
thank you uh chair uh not unsurprisingly
I find myself taking the country of you
um I think my first a couple of
observations first of all I think we're
wasting our time getting knotted up in
the uh in the register itself it's a
secondary source the only interesting
piece of information is that there's no
identified request for self-build infini
Compton and I think it is a secondary
piece of additional information
there's nothing as I understand it in
the act that overrides the duty to build
stuff in the right place
and our policies
um If This Were a bog standard Housing
Development would it this would have
been a delegated refusal if it had got
to committee full stop this is only here
because it's self-built
um we have a neighborhood development
plan that was made in April and I have
and speaking as a portfolio holder who's
guided all the neighborhood development
plans through for the last four and a
bit years
um
what would being asked to accept is that
because the NDP is silent on the
question of self-build that it's not in
non-conformity it's been in front of an
examination by an inspector who didn't
pick that up wasn't picked up by the
policy team
um my view is that the inspector was
satisfied that if any Compton identified
a housing need
um there is only a requirement well it
it has to identify a housing need the
absence of
identifying a housing need for
self-build doesn't mean to say that it
has to reference self-build that's like
you know more than Belton braces
um the NDP is clear that this
development is unacceptable and it's an
NDP that's been made and we should give
great weight to it's outside the built
up area boundary regardless of its
tenure or its um
uh the nature of the build
um we have been asked to to back away
from the NDP because it's silent on the
question of self-build and I don't think
that's the right conclusion to come to I
think that we should refuse this on the
basis that it's not in Conformity with
self-built sorry not in Conformity with
the ndp's development
uh policies I think it's de2 I think is
the one that if we get to it if I can
get back in for a refusal we'll we'll
come to that
um and frankly
on a personal note I think it's worth
testing because we are if
if this gets appealed and an inspector
says yet the absence of that single
sentence then we know where we are but
at the moment we're second guessing this
I'm quite happy to to put forward with
back the NDP and if they appeal it let's
let the planning inspector actually give
everybody clarity about this question
because not only us but other
authorities up and down the land have
got a similar problem about being silent
on the question of self-build and I come
back to we should be building self-build
in the right places
if and this is not the right place
because we've already agreed it's
outside the built-up area boundary and
inspector has decided to plan
that says that is sound so I'd be
looking to put a contrary proposition
and would be seeking a seconder for that
I may or may not get that
thank you councilor Pemberton I believe
I saw councilor Harvey's hand up first
you graciously get handing over to
counselor Perry
I I personally think
that this is an unusual situation from
the previous
self-built applications we've had
because in those parishes the
neighborhood development plan had been
made one or two or three years ago this
is a new situation because the
neighborhood development plan has been
made April
2023 when both our policy team the
planning inspectorate knows about the
current issues of self-build and custom
build housing and therefore
I I would like to Second counselor
pemberton's because I do believe
that this is a unique situation because
the neighborhood development plan has
been made in April three or four months
ago it's gone through the scrutiny of
the planning inspector we have been
having
within this Council issues with
self-built and custom build sites for 18
months
18 months so if it wasn't in fenney
Compton it should have been if necessary
picked up either by the policy team or
by the planning inspectorate and then it
could have been referred back to the
Paris parish for a policy or a decision
on self-build it was very different on
the wells-borne site their NDP was made
back in in 2018 2017
I think this is an exception to the rule
um I also think there is an element of
weight because of Penny Compton's
location in the district at the very far
east
of the district and there isn't
one element of any demand for the fenney
Compton area or in fact other
settlements that are adjacent to fenney
Compton so that whole area
is absent so
um I will have pleasure in seconding
councilor Pemberton to re to go against
the officer's recommendation thank you
chair thank you very much councilor
Harvey
thank you chairman
um
I am caught on a dilemma
because uh
I'm very concerned that we have a policy
CIS CS 15 and 16 about the dish which
are required the distribution of of
development within the district
and we have in my view for too long
accepted the argument that because past
inspectors have said these numbers
within cs16 are guidelines they are not
maximums
then virtually anything has gone and
that's why you've now got some
settlements which have got more than 200
percent of their allotted uh figure
which is there on the basis of no more
than around Infinity Compton's case this
this is already at over 150 percent if
this development were to be permitted it
would be over 160 percent I do not
personally regard plain English to mean
that no more than around means means
that if I was talking in in the context
of a policeman and speeding limits there
would there would be there would be an
allowance of 10
usually a rule of thumb not written down
anywhere but well understood amongst the
motoring public that 10 33 in the 30
limit won't get you a fine
that's a common sense approach
I could stretch that to 20 in this in
this particular instance of cs16 but but
50 is not no more than around
when it comes to inspectors decisions I
know that the officer is right to say
there are a number of decisions which
show that this these numbers are there
for guidance and they aren't there for
maximums
but I will hang my hat on the decision
in the earlswood case where the
inspector said explicitly that the
number in the policy is the maximum now
we can't have inspectors telling us two
two different things in opposite
directions and leave us to pick the
bones and come to a right decision I'm
with a councilor Pemberton in the sense
that I would like to test this decision
um I think the the question of the NDP
and its uh recent approval in April is a
reflection on what what people in fenney
Compton want this is outside the
built-up area they've had more than
their fair share more than and then
around the the required 12 percent
and so I'm inclined
to vote to reject on the other hand I do
respect what the officers say and the
statutory obligations there are under
the 2015 Act so I am caught in the
Dilemma
well I'll come to you councilor pempton
in a second um just to that point and I
think in reference to something that Mr
Bach said earlier uh with regards to CS
1516 and as10 on page 22 of the office's
report it does apply oh and the NDP
policy de to does apply moderate weight
in determination of the application
um no I don't want to misquote Mr Barker
but I believe he said they were
irrelevant at one point whereas
it does seem that there is
way too forward to them within the
report how we determine that here it's
obviously for us to decide but I just
thought I'd highlight that Council
Pemberton
thank you chair if I can help uh
councilor Harvey off the fence I'd be
happy to
um I would be happy for uh for to expand
the reasons for refusal to Encompass the
question of
um
uh the the numbers around LS fees
my main thrust and where I give full
weight is the NDP as a decision maker
so but I can see there is some at least
secondary support secondary reason for
refusal around
um the application based on the question
of numbers for Philly Compton
and councilor Harvey is right on both
counts inspectors have said it's a it's
not a maximum uh the Oswald inspector
took a different view but I think there
is a common sense question around uh the
the the burden on the lsvs you know we
have a Top Line District number in the
say that we same way we have as Top Line
District number for self and custom
build so I I'm happy to but if councilor
Parry is happy as a second to help
counselor Harvey along with that
thank you councilor Ed and next
I am all
um thank you chair uh I am very much on
the side of councilor's Pemberton Parry
on this one
um the main decider for me is is
definitely that policy in the NDP that
is explicit about the built-up area
boundary and not notwithstanding the
fact that ndps are backed up by housing
needs survey that say we don't need any
I mean in terms of local data
that for me is a a big sway in this
um
just going back to perhaps a couple of
things that Council of rock mentioned in
his speech that you read out
um there's no school there's no shop
it's unsustainable without a car
these are other
cumulative matters for me that that make
me feel that I want to go against this
and and back cancel the Pemberton and
Parry with their thrust
thank you councilor councilor Keithley
next
yes thanks chair
um
I
I've heard what's been said I'm leaning
towards councilor Pemberton and
councilor Harvey's view on this
um what I think though is quite
important is that the the the
policies that we are supposed to be
testing this against if it wasn't self
and custom built
um we would be looking at a
recommendation for refusal I think I'm
concerned that the NDP is only given
moderate weight with these policies and
I think in I respect the opinion
obviously of the the case officer but I
think that the NDP should be given
greater weight
uh greater than moderate weight
but most importantly I'd go back to what
councilor Pemberton said that he didn't
think the the data was was all that were
perhaps that key but I think it is
because what we've heard tonight from
our legal advisor
is that we can consider secondary data
and some of that secondary data if I'm
correct in repeating it can take account
of more detailed locations of the demand
for self and custom-built housing
and I would like
that secondary data to be tested as well
as the uh the weight given to the core
policies and the NDP
so I'm in favor of the proposal if I
think I'm writing saying a proposal was
made by councilor Pemberton but I would
like to
add to that consideration of the weight
that we give to secondary data that
we're entitled to give to secondary data
which show more about the granularity of
the location for the demand of this type
of property
thank you through you chair in Broad
terms I'm comfortable with that I think
however if we get to it if there is a
does if the if this committee does
resolve to refuse and then we're going
to be asked about reasons for refusal I
think it's my I I'm maintaining that we
lead with the NDP
um we follow up with
um
cs16 yep and we also then and then we
follow on with we've also given some
weight in our decision making to a
number of areas of secondary data
referencing uh the spreadsheet
referencing and I'll I'll come to you
for some for some help on the wording on
the other secondary pieces there so
we've got a layered approach there
because I think for me our principal
reason is it's not in accordance with
the NDP and I'm firmly of the view we
can give full weight through an NDP
that's almost five minutes ago been
through an examination inspector in
public been found to be sand found to be
in Conformity and I know that uh Mr
Barker and I are taking different views
on that but that is a wonderful thing
democracy
thank you um I actually have a possibly
more of a question which might just um
uh satisfy something I I I think the
world member raised in his statement
um under the
other matters part of the report page 34
it talks about climate change
sustainable Construction
now this was made
um this has been raised in debate and
obviously was raised by War members
comments
um It's relatively short section and
effectively goes on to say that the
climate change checklist was not
required at this stage being an outline
application
um as this is in my view a pertinent
aspect of of our considerations can I
ask the officers
how how much weight the um the impact
that this will have in terms of car use
Etc
um can be considered within the planning
process albeit that we've got to fairly
you know non-resolving uh paragraphs in
the report
I'll say that um
the the category of settlement is
identified as a category two settlement
within the core strategy which is
identified as a being a sustainable
location
um within the call strategy
foreign
I'm satisfied with that
um
remember so do we have any further
comments for the debate
um we have a proposal uh from councilor
Pemberton second did by councilor Perry
um I need to make sure I mean we've been
fairly um expansive in exhaustive in our
reasoning I think
um Mr Barker do you have the reasons
down that you are able to
use in our reason for refusal
chairman I think as as is often the case
in these circumstances we'd like your
agreement to the precise wording uh
tomorrow or subsequently
um but we've got a fair idea of of
what's concerning members uh we feel
that your concern is centered around uh
policy de2 of the fenne Compton
neighborhood development plan
uh which is concerned with development
being focused inside the Builder period
boundary
so because it's outside the buildup area
boundary you you feel you're that we're
at conflict with the uh neighborhood
plan
and that it doesn't conform with any of
the types of residential development
supported by as-10 again relating back
to to de2
and in addition that the village has
substantially exceeded the uh numbers of
dwellings identified in cs-16
I'm being waved up by councilor
Pemberton
okay uh and therefore it we're
identifying conflict with both the
fenney Compton neighborhood plan and
with core strategy cs16
um
and I think that that's the the flavor
of the reason that I think members are
asking me to write
chair I think
um I think again uh the wording three
will be through you chair but I think
um as decision makers we are giving full
weight to the NDP and we are considering
and
um with a view to any future action we
have and did consider the question about
it being silent on SCB and we're
satisfied that that being silent did not
make the policy in non-conformity and
were bolstered in that view by the fact
that it had recently gone through an
examination in public
um I think that also to pick up
councilor keithley's point of view that
uh Point rather that we also considered
a number of secondary sources and gave
some weight to those secondary sources
being the
um the analysis of location request in
the SCB register and uh other secondary
sources of information housing need
survey and some others if you want to
chip in there counselor Keithley about
some others I think it's just about
making sure we've got that layer because
I am thinking further forward about the
potential the uh day after tomorrow uh
are you are you comfortable with that Mr
Barker I'm comfortable with that
chairman uh but can I ask
does that mean members are asking us to
address secondary sources in future
reports on self and custom-built housing
that's going to be quite a big job for
your policy team
I think there's General nods from around
the room on that and the debate
certainly lends itself to it uh
councilor Harvey can I just be clear in
relation to my arguments about cs-16
that the reason for refusal concerning
cs16 is that fenney Compton has provided
more than around the 12 percent
because if this is going to go to appeal
the inspector I'd ask the inspector to
address that question from that way
around not the other way around
elsewhere Keith
just a point for the planning officer
um this issue of secondary data
um I'm just reading again from page 23
and it says specifically that a local
planning Authority should use demand
data from the register supported by
additional data to understand the need
for this type of Housing and what I
would say in this particular case that
we haven't seen any evidence at all that
supports an argument to deliver this
specific type of housing in this General
locality
all right I think we're um we're about
there and uh We've certainly given uh Mr
Parker a lot to be working with so the
proposal is to refuse the application
wording to be
delegated to officers uh with my
agreement kind of see all those in favor
opposed
okay so committee resolves to refuse
application
22-02138 o u t
thank you very much everybody
very brief recess
okay when we're back uh now moving on to
item number four which is application 23
01068 ful and the date adjacent to four
bellfield Tamworth in Arden our
presenting officer is Victoria Kempton
and when you're ready take it away
good evening and thank you
for one bedroom Bungalow within
bellfield in town within Arden and the
site is identified by the black dot on
the map
the site is now outlined in red and the
plan illustrates the boundaries of the
conservation area to the south and west
of the site outlined in purple
the site also lies within the green belt
on special landscape area and area of
archaeological sensitivity
the site lies at the entrance of
Belfield which loops around to serve
residential dwellings and a Bowling
Green to the east
these are the elevations of the proposed
Bungalows showing a simple
double-fronted design the height of the
dwelling would be around six meters
whilst the width would be around 8.5
meters
the development is proposed to be
finished in Brick and concrete roof
tiles although the date of the materials
could be subject to condition
you can see that no Upper Floor Windows
have been proposed
the floor plan shows a one bedroom
dwelling with the main living
accommodation being to the side of the
property
the site plan shows that there would
also be a small garden to the bounded by
the existing hedge to the rear with a
new hedge being added to the front
one allocated parking space is proposed
with an additional unallocated parking
space being possible
there's also a gas substation shown here
and a margin of land has been provided
just in front of that to allow for
access
I wish to highlight that a garden shed
has also been proposed here and an air
source heat pump is here
so these photos show the site which is
covered in hard standing and is used for
informal off-sheet parking a drop curb
also runs along the highway Edge
photo number one shows a relationship of
number three vicarage hill behind the
sides
over here
in addition to the substation which is
forward of a group of trees there's
photo number two shows the parking area
more clearly and in the background is
assigned for an overflow car park here
the first two photos show the character
of the homes in Belfield with the site
in the background the road is narrow
with on-street parking
the third photo shows bellfield in the
winter where you can see how the homes
are arranged around the central green
Terraces have a simple architectural
detail built within the 20th century
at the end of the road there's a row of
Terrace Bungalows over here
this aerial image shows how the site is
positioned at the entrance of Belfield
whilst also showing the relationship of
neighboring homes
so in conclusion the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions listed in the report there
have been several updates as listed on
the update sheets thank you Jeff thank
you very much
excuse me when I move on to our first
Speaker who is Pete Lees representing
residents of bellfield
good evening Miss Lee's you have three
minutes
oh yeah button on the right and they'll
make the microphone go live I'll give
you a 30 second warning otherwise start
when you're ready
I am Pete Lees representing the
residents of bellfield and a lot of the
villagers who have not formally objected
car parking which is application for
this Bungalow is May is made was built
by Stratford District Council back in
the early 1950s and the ownership passed
on to what is now orbit Housing
Association
no Covenant was put in the transfer to
keep the car Parks as car Parks
unfortunately
today Stratford district council could
take that away from us
that hurts
this has been a long battle firstly with
orbit Housing Association not to sell at
auction
which they did unfortunately
the other car park by the Bowling Green
was sold and developed with a big
percentage of the land sale profit going
to Stratford District Council I'm not
talking about you personally
no money was put back into bellfield at
all I want to add
this car park is the only one left for
the whole village which
is used extensively particularly by The
Village Hall which is just only a few
yards down the road
the local Templeton Island parish
council did bid at the auction as they
need someplace to put some charging
points for electric cars and this site
is perfect as is right next to the
electric substation
the parish council will shortly be
taking over the whole of bellfield
circular Road and Central Green from
orbit after orbit wanted to get rid of
the responsibility of maintaining it
just wanted you to know that it's
important
this application by Mr Zane and his
architect has changed many many times
from the large two-bedroom to a smaller
one bed to try and comply with the
planning laws and all the detailed
objections
some have still not been answered in
this application
the planning officer has their job to do
even though I've met her on site we have
to say we are a bit disappointed with
the major technical issues that have
been ignored
for example she does not think that
parking is an issue in bellfield look at
the 20 formal objections that went in to
yourselves
all about parking mostly
the Belfield main seal goes directly
under the proposed Bungalow that serves
all the houses in bellfield
there's a major gas substation that
serves the whole of the village on the
site
however
you the playing committee are the people
who add some common sense to proceedings
we residents rely and urge you to use
common sense and refuse it bellfield is
full
thank you very much well within your
time
members do you have any questions for
our speaker
no yes Carla Keithley thank you chair
um thank you very much for that could
you just explain the situation regarding
parking on bellfield
um
I I took a visit staying on Pub on um
you know Public public rows but I could
see people were able to park and and get
round I mean why is it that I saw that
people were parking on this on the
street
and and that seemed to be acceptable so
it looked to be widened at one point as
well with different tarmac is that
correct
thank you well spotted yeah on the
left-hand side as you look into
bellfield the road has been widened in
the past down to Road level I know curb
moved back so that people on that side
can part but they now they they park on
the footpath because it's too narrow
even with that on the right hand side
that an overtaking strip was built
which only lorries and vans can use
so what you get is people
on my side of the road number four five
six seven eight down the road that's a
very old picture by the way the bottom
picture the trees you've taken out I
don't know where you got that from that
must be 15 years old
um
on the right hand side and yeah the
turmerican strips not over the
overtaking strips not there is it I
can't
no anyhow um
basically all those people down on that
side of the road don't park in front of
the houses because there's been so many
accidents where cars have scraped each
other because they've tried to go within
the road but it's just not wide enough
you have to go on the overtaking strip
and I did suggest to section 106
agreement
um to actually lower it down if
the worst cups are the worst
for me I'm just a clarification on the
day that I visited there was a car
parked on the right hand side down there
I think your house is one of the first
ones isn't it so it was probably three
houses down but he was parked on the
side of the road seemed to be no
particular
issues that I could see from from where
I was which was sort of roughly where
this photo has taken
it's 3.9 meters in front of my house
before and the road widens and wides and
widens as it gets towards the bottom end
so as you get towards the bottom end it
is possible to get two cars to pass but
at the pinch point in front of our house
is 3.9 meters
any further questions from our speaker
knowing which case uh thank you very
much
okay we now move on to our next speaker
um
good evening uh you've also got three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning and uh it's the button on the
right hand side
just on the right
uh in
yeah the silver button on the right hand
side in the middle
yeah there you go
thank you awesome and um yeah like I
said I'll give you a 30 second warning
otherwise start when you're ready okay
This Land Is private land and although
it has been used by residents on the
street for additional parking it is not
within their property or ownership and
ultimately the previous owner of the
land put it up for sale land first went
on sale with a guy price of 20 000 in
mid December 2021 and it was sold for
thirty thousand it was later put up
again for auction on 19th of May 2022 at
a guy price of 25 000 and it was sold at
twenty eight thousand there were two
windows opportunities for anyone to pull
money together and buy this land it begs
the question if the car park was so
important to retain then why did no one
purchase the site
my clients purchased the site and we did
a successful pre-avid Stratford Council
for a dwelling house then proceeded
naturally to a full planning application
which has been recommended for approval
I think it is also worth mentioning that
there's been misinformation circulating
around regarding side being unsuitable
for development due to its close
proximity with an electric and gas
substation this is incorrect we
independently have spoken to both
National Grid and Caden gas who have
come out to do their on-site
investigation and have both confirmed
that site is perfectly suitable for
development
I also had a quote from one of the
residents on the battlefield who will
remain anonymous anonymous for
confidential confidentiality reason they
stated that not all the residents of
Belfield Road were consulted before
signing on behalf of the whole of
Battlefield
having read the objections I can
appreciate the frustration expressed in
the comments received however it is not
suitable platform to raise these
concerns as they are not planning
related matters and it certainly does
not mean one can force themselves on a
private property as an architect and
designer I can see a solution that can
work and will eliminate the ongoing
parking and circulation issues wide in
the road and use the green space more
creatively to integrate planting
landscaping and parking spaces for all
of Battlefield to use
this can be achieved by employing a
landscape architect who will be able to
provide sustainable solution that need
that meets everyone needs but wrongfully
trying to claim private land is unfair
especially when there are there were two
separate opportunities to pull together
and acquire the land
we have worked with the planning officer
to deal with the design constraints and
concerns and the revised plans offer a
single-story one-bedroom Bungalow which
will be perfect as a starter home for a
small family or a retired couple and
will contribute to the housing demand
effectively while enhancing the local
Street Scene and Community thank you for
listening
well within your time thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our speaker councilor Eden
good evening
um
you in your speech you made a lot of
point about it being private land
um do you think uh
from your client's point of view it's
a possibility that without any planning
permission he could simply fence that
area off
as it stairs
um there is am I still on but there is
obviously always a potential that he can
do that he says right within his right
to do so
but obviously we're not we don't want to
you know argue with the neighbors we
don't want to upset anyone so we are
working with everyone on the street
and just try and resolve this issue and
be actually personally met some of the
residents on the battlefield before
submitting the application to try and
listen to their concern but as I said in
my speech some of them are not planning
related unfortunately and I can't help
with those comments as an architect
thank you councilor Perry
thank you chair
um you mentioned in your presentation
that the local residents could use the
green area in the middle of the the that
is in the center uh of where the
residents are
um
on that basis do you
do you do you know who owns that land
that can give them some some help on the
advice I mean I believe it's with the
parish council now it's so the parish
council owned that Central bit of land I
think or you think according to my
information and that's why you're
suggesting that they could use that land
for parking yeah I think
thank you any further questions for our
speaker
no in which case thank you very much
very good uh we now move on to our final
speaker the ward member councilor organ
uh two seconds I haven't got you on the
list but I'll just check with our
officers
foreign
I'm very sorry to say that Paris Clark
actually um got in touch with our
officers after the deadline
and so you weren't registered to speak
for this evening
um
unfortunately because of the other
speakers we've had as well that you
speaking would allocate time to other
people who have already spoken as well
and so it would disrupt how their
contributions would be heard within the
setting of the meeting
um I understand that
um both yourself and the ward member
have a similar view on this based on the
reasons for referral for committee
broadly speaking I would hope that
her contribution as she is here tonight
would address your concerns
um I'm afraid that's all I can do in
which case we'll move on to the ward
members contribution
foreign
councilor
good evening councilors
this proposal is completely at odds with
the built environment of Belfield which
is 50 Cent character designed around a
green space that reflects the Village
Green
as such it is quite clearly contrary to
policy cs9 cs20 and the Tamworth NDP
policy be1
paragraph 5 4 of tanworth NDP explains
the background and objectives of policy
be one it clearly states that new
buildings should reflect the local
character and goes on to say that
building materials and design
characteristics should be in harmony
with the original adjacent properties
this isn't
policy cs9 says proposals will be
sensitive to the setting and existing
built form
this isn't instead it upsets the Harmony
and balance of bellfield
it removes an important amenity space
that is part of the original design and
setting of Belford bellfield providing
much needed parking for residents and
visitors its removal will mean that the
crisis in parking provision for
residents will get worse
on the north side of bellfield on street
parking is possible for those properties
but only if there was just one car per
household given the rural nature of
tanworth two vehicles per household is
Not Unusual tanworth NDP paragraph 4.5
identifies that car ownership is much
higher than other parts of the district
and on the South Side as we've heard
there is the narrowing that makes it
very congested
the site for this proposed Bungalow is
quite clearly a much used and valued
amenity car park an essential car park
tanwithin Arden was created before the
Advent of the Motorcar and the village
roads are now embroidered with the
border of parked cars especially
evenings when everyone is home
so how is it good planning to permit the
removal of this car
where will residents and visitors Park
once it's gone
tanwithin Arden has a well-used Bowling
Green and is accessed from bellfield
there is no parking on the Bowling Green
site the parking is here on this site
there is a sign on this site that says
it all
you can't see it there but I'll tell you
what's on it overflow car park residents
visitors Village Hall church school and
Bowling Green
it says all you need to know about the
lack of parking in the village the
removal of these spaces will create
Havoc where will everyone Park will it
affect the viability of the Bowling Club
um I wish to bring you to your attention
the evidence that this is and always has
been a car park not an informal parking
area
there is a dropped curb all the way
along the road Frontage this was created
when the estate was built if you examine
the surface of the car park you can
still still see the lined markings for
the parking base
in addition to local character and
design principles policy B1 of the NDP
says that there should be sufficient
well-located parking spaces in
accordance with part o of the district
council's development requirements SPD
this is to help remove the need for any
on-road parking
whilst the proposed development will
provide sufficient parking for a
one-bedroom Bungalow it will not
compensate for the removal of many
well-used parking spaces
thus because the proposal removes
well-used parking spaces and results in
adding to on-road parking it achieves
precisely the opposite to the intention
of the policy
so that's okay then
is it a good planning balance within an
historic village showing the limit of
being able to cope to remove essential
parking spaces needed for residents
businesses and visitors no it isn't
policy cs20 seeks to ensure that
development takes place in a manner that
minimizes and mitigates its impact on
the landscape character and quality of
the district this proposal clearly does
not achieve that objective in addition a
minor point the porch fails to comply
with the guidance of Part D of the
development requirements there's three
SPD
I urge you to consider the overall
effect of this proposed development
which will be to cause chaos on the
local roads thank you
thank you very much councilor members do
we have any questions for a world member
councilor I have first then Mary
um good evening Council organ
um I wonder if you can tell me two
numbers if you could number one would be
how many parking spaces are there on
this particular site and secondly how
many houses are there in tanworth in
Arden so I can get scale and and
appropriateness
you need to turn your microphone on
sorry I forgot I switched it off
um you can park 18 cars on there but
it's not lined out for 18 cars Tamworth
population The Village itself
about 500 I suppose but it is a small
village that has a huge hinter line
catchment that comes into it
comes to Barry
thank you chair good evening councilor
organ
um
we've heard this evening that this
particular parking area is in private
ownership
therefore it's
um the owner could
fence
the area off
or could introduce
no parking rules with a clamping
provision by an outside agency and the
residents wouldn't have anywhere to park
could you just respond to how that would
impact and how would you would deal with
that situation
well it would be devastating because
there isn't enough space in bellfield
for residents to park without
obstructing the refuse wagons and
delivery wagons if they go out onto
vicarage Hill that's already full in the
evenings with the Cottages that are
along vicarage Hill that then go down
into the The Village itself there isn't
anywhere else to park and with regard to
the land being in private ownership
yes it is but then so our NCP car parks
and their car Parks I think the tenure
of the land really is
no
the point the point is it is an existing
parking area
thank you um I actually have a question
are you aware of a parking survey having
been carried out at all
um in relation to this
I cannot recall one though
members any further questions for our
award member
no don't believe so in which case thank
you very much
uh we now move on to points of
clarification from our officer
counselor homes
um am I right in saying that there's no
Covenant on the site for it to remain as
car parking facility
that wouldn't be relevant because that's
only relevant to the ownership which
wouldn't be a plan of matter
because Keith
thank you chair yeah um
this is a question relating to the
um overlooking an amenity of the
property
behind the proposed
Bungalow so I'm on page 50.
and I just wanted to get a little bit of
clarification on the potential impact of
the proposed development in terms of its
overlooking because you're proposing to
remove PD rights
to to to stop any second floor
development or Dormer windows
could you can you help me a little bit
in terms of what you stated that the
proposed development breaches a sight
line
from number three but the 25 degree
sight line would be unaffected so you
were satisfied the development would not
result in a harmful overbearing or
overshadowing impact because I'm aware
that
I'm a third-party representation
mentioned the potential impact on
number three
thank you so I'll start with the
overlooking
um so Part F of the development
requirements SPD sets out some
separation distances and that includes
windows for
um rooms at first floor level
um as none have been proposed
um it obviously complies with the
windows facing directly neighboring
properties and that is why we I have
recommended a condition to remove
permitted development rights to convert
the roof space and then secondly in
terms of the 45-25 degree sight line
I've tried to depict the 45 degree test
on the left as well as I can so you can
see here that the property clearly
impacts the 45 degree sight line there
where it crosses because it's at a
slight angle it's an imperfect
assessment so I've done it done a 25
degree test twice on both elevations for
each of the distances to the the lowest
point and the ridge you can see both
tests are met
so because the 25 degree site test has
been met that would occurred with the
test as per Part F but within that
assessment I've also taken into account
the orientation of the properties I've
indicated the north North here so the
impact on the the overshadowing impacts
are lessened by by the orientation
thank you very much Victoria yeah that's
that's very good and I can see the
orientation means that number three is
in fact to the south of this property so
the sun's on this side that's important
thank you thanks very much thank you any
further points of clarification
in which case we can move to debate to
let's start
castlepari
thank you chair
um firstly I think I would like to
sympathize with all the residents of
bellfield
um
because clearly
it's very hard when you've always parked
somewhere or had the facility to park
somewhere
that is safe that is off the road
there's a voice your car getting
scratched
um
but from where I'm looking at this
I don't see that as a material planning
reason
to refuse
um
we have a shortage of small dwellings
I think this
there has been comments that it doesn't
fit with the character but there are
Bungalows nearby
um it's not a case of over development
there is Garden immunity space
um
and again I have every sympathy with the
bell-filled residence
but I'm going to propose and go with the
officer's recommendation
thank you very much councilor Keithley
well
um likewise
um I I can completely understand the
people living on bellfield are
um
I'm really disappointed that this very
long-standing piece of amenity land that
they've been able to use may be taken
away but what we've heard is that
um it's now in private ownership and and
that means that that owner has got
rights to develop and improve that piece
of land in accordance with our planning
policies and we we can't
um we can't we can't
make a judgment on the fact that that
piece of land is now in private
ownership and it shouldn't be and it
should still be a car park because
unfortunately it's been purchased when I
visited site I could see there was
parking but I also noticed quite a lot
of parking on vicarage hill and although
there were quite a few people in the pub
I noticed that when I visited the area
um the few cars that were there on the
car parking space about three or four
um I think could have found
um an alternative place but that was my
my opinion and I'm I'm a guess that
along with councilor Parry I'd be
disappointed if if my car parking
amenity was disappearing but then again
in private ownership we've got to
respect the fact that the owner of that
property is entitled to develop it
um so
um in that respect I would be prepared
to Second counselor Perry's proposal to
um
to uh to accept the officer's
recommendation which is to Grant Subject
to the conditions and the removal of the
PD rights and kind of thank the officer
for explaining the impact of the
overbearing and light on the neighboring
property
thank you very much any further comments
from Embers
uh no it doesn't look like anyone else
clamoring to uh to add to the debate
um in which case I'm quite happy to take
the proposal in the second that's been
put forward
um so that's proposal to Grant in line
with the officer's recommendations and
the update sheet
can't see all those in favor
unanimous
in which case uh committee resolves to
Grant application
23-01068 ful
um now going to move on to our final
application which is
um
item number six application
23-01650 slash very eleven Lawson Avenue
tiddington
uh presenting officer is Sarah Leech and
once she's uh in situ um you can take it
away
thank you chair
uh the application sorry this
application is being presented at
committee as the applicant is a council
employee the application seeks A
variation to an extant permission for a
single story rate and power side
extension granted in April 2023.
the variation is to condition two which
refers to the approved drawings
the application seeks to increase the
height of the rear extension by 0.45
meters and replace the roof lantern with
a flat roof light the application site
is 11 Lawson Avenue in tiddington which
is denoted by the black dot
this plan identifies the application
site outlined in red
the application site is not within a
conservation area or any other
designation
these are the approved and proposed site
plan there is no increase in floor space
so there is no change between these two
plans
um
here are the approved elevational
drawings under the previous application
and below are the proposed elevations
with the flat with the flat roof light
and the increase in the height of the
rear extension
here are some photographs of the
application site
there is limited uh public views of the
rear elevation
the recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to conditions
thanks very much Sarah now we've got no
registered speakers for this item so
we'll go straight to points
clarification
it doesn't appear that we have any
points of clarification so can we move
to the debate it looks like councilor
Pemberton has proposed
councilor Harvey
do we have any further comments to the
debate
know in which case proposal is to Grant
in line with the officer's
recommendations kind of see all those in
favor please unanimously good committee
resolves to Grant application
23-01650 very
for what it's worth Sarah there won't
always be that easy
for what it's worth you won't always
have Dale
um